bonjour à tous et à toutes je viens de
refaire le carrelage de ma salle de bain
avec des carreaux pentagonaux oui car
j'adore les pentagone sauf que en fait
ça fait un carrelage avec trou a dit hrw
et loire we are et aurait peut-être dû
utiliser d'autres formes de pentagone
d'ailleurs le problème de quart et sa
salle de bain avec des peintres est
bonne c'est un sac les frais de
mathématiques et justement michael hao
un informaticien théorique vient de
mettre un terme à un siècle de
recherches mathématiques sur la
classification des pavages mono carreau
par pentagone complexe alors avant le
théorème de raho
on connaissait déjà pas mal de carrelage
par pentagone convexe en 1918 le
mathématicien carl reiner at least les
cinq premières familles de pentagone qui
peuvent le plan 5 c'est déjà bien sauf
qu'en 1968 nous mathématicien richarde
cash nord ajoute trois nouvelles
familles à cette liste et il affirme
avoir le stock complet mais en 1975
l'informaticien richard james découvrit
une neuvième famille de portails web et
ce n'est pas fini
en 1977 marguerie rice une femme au
foyer sans formation mathématique
humilie kershner en découvrant quatre
nouvelles familles et pim et enfin en
2015 une quinzième famille de pentagone
est découverte par le mathématicien
casey man et ses collaborateurs dont il
y en a combien on va continuer longtemps
comme ça oui c'est vrai que trouver de
nouvelles familles de pentagone c'est
cool mais ce qui est vraiment ambitieux
difficile est satisfaisant c'est de tout
les trouver et de prouver qu'on les a
tout et c'est justement ce qu'a fait
michael rao en mai 2010 est le génie de
hao c'est de ramener un problème qui
paraît infini un problème fini qui peut
être résolu par un ordinateur
et c'est très surprenant quand vous y
réfléchissez le nombre de familles de
pentagone a priori c'est infini et le
nombre de façons de les arranger pour
paver le plan ça aussi a priori c'est
infini mais grâce à un premier logiciel
rao a suivi identifié un ensemble fini
de 371 familles candidates
il a démontré que pour tous pentagone
n'appartenant pas à ces familles il est
impossible de pavés un plan attention ça
ne veut pas dire que c'est 371 famille
conviennent pour un pavage juste que si
un pentagone peu pavé le plan alors il
fait forcément partie de l'une d'elles
hao ensuite développé un second logiciel
qui détermine lesquels de ces 371
famille de pentagone pouvait réellement
pavé le plan bon la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que l'ordinateur n'a pas trouvé
d'autres familles de pentagone autre que
celle qu'on connaissait déjà mais la
bonne nouvelle c'est que ceci prouve
qu'il n'existe pas de nouvelles familles
de pentagone
d'où le théorème de hao un pentagone
convexe pav le plan si et seulement s'il
appartient à l'une de ces quinze
familles j'ai décidé d'utiliser des
carreaux de formes différentes voilà
mais le pavage multiforme c'est beaucoup
trop complexe à je peux plus tu es des
bas non mais t'es vache tu me laisse sur
le carreau là je suis pavage pas vache
pavage si t'es fier de ta salle de bains
abonne toi et va voir cents vols